>> And so here's that code in practice, the first thing we do is loop through
each of the tileSets images, checking the firstgid against the tileIndex. Once
we find the correct one, we'll break out knowing that i is the proper index.
Once we find this, we can set the pkt.img value to equal the image of the atlas,
and then we go through and do a little bit of math to determine what the tile
offset is. Now, recall that the tile index is actually added to the firstgid for
this array. So, 167 as a tile index, is actually atlas with gid1. Tile 166. We
remedy this by actually subtracting the tileIndex from the firstgid, giving us
localIdx. From there, we can do a little simple math, given the localIdx and the
numXTiles horizontally for this atlas to give us to give us our x and y indexes.
Once we have the indexes, we can multiply them by the tileSize to give us our px
and py. Finally, return pkt, and we're good to go.